right now
a building that had survived two
earthquakes in southern turkey now gone
a car dash cam captures the moment
a woman screams the Earth trembled all
the buildings in Hattie have collapsed
they are dead
[Applause]
and at the airport Panic as the Quake
hit
[Applause]
the politician's television interview
from an Aid distribution center
interrupted
[Music]
for families already traumatized
disbelief the terror has come again
we were very scared we thought the
ground would tear apart
a nation rocked just two weeks after
twin earthquakes upended the lives of
millions killing tens of thousands and
destroying countless homes
it was very shaky you know we hardly
stood up
it was very difficult you know you know
it was gonna happen we were expecting
that so
right now so we're expecting more
so everybody should be you know
more prepared about this
this is the moment the Quake struck
Aleppo in rebel-held Northern Syria
more misery for people still suffering
severe shortages in food medicine and
housing on top of a decade-old civil war
[Music]
the situation in Syria I mean it's
horrible in Northwest Syria let's say
it's horrible this devastated area even
before the earthquake now is suffering
more and more all those people in fact
who have been directly affected or even
those people who have been indirectly
affected are living very severe in
conditions
back in turkey's mayor says people are
trapped under the rubble While others
have poured into the streets another
night in the cold
turkia
well the Quake struck near the city of
antakia let's speak to Assad big that's
where he is right now I said I believe a
huge rescue operation going on where you
are what more can you tell us
well rescue workers have been working
throughout the night since that
earthquake hit now we understand that
there were four men inside this building
when that hit and the building collapsed
trapping them inside now one man has
been recovered three are still inside we
understand that the rescue workers have
located two of those men are working to
try and get them out now we've been
hearing the Machinery working behind us
and the workers going in and out now no
one was living in in these buildings
what actually happened was that these
men had come to take away some of their
belongings despite the warnings from
authorities telling people not to go
inside buildings never understand they
had a van here and they were going to
take their belongings out when that
earthquake hit now we've been speaking
to some of the rescue workers and they
said the rescue workers actually some of
them had been leaving the area they had
been winding down the operations what
was actually taking place was recovery
operations looking for body when this
earthquake hit they didn't expect it to
hit yes there's been aftershocks there's
been thousands of aftershocks but no one
expected another earthquake at least so
soon just two weeks after uh the other
two that devastated this region now
around this area there's demolished
buildings the ones that are still
standing are severely damaged but when
this earthquake hit it caused Panic we
saw people at petrol stations filling up
their cars saying that they weren't
going back to their homes they're going
to spend the night sleeping in their
cars we saw people out on the streets
wrapped in blankets come out of their
homes saying that they don't want to go
back inside they still felt scared and
when you have those aftershocks and when
you had that earthquake it makes people
relive that trauma it's it that fear
reemerges and there is a sense of panic
in some places but at least here we've
been seeing the rescue workers go up and
down working away trying to free those
men now we understand that they have
located two of them but the third one
they haven't located yet but they're
working to free those two
in the last few hours there's been
several teams going in and out of that
building behind me I said tell us a bit
more about what the mood is like there I
mean these people have already lived
through two earthquakes now another one
in under two weeks
people are feeling anxious there's fear
they're scared
because like I said these aftershocks
have continued thousands of them and now
our earthquake 6.4 on the Richter scale
and there's reports that there's three
rescue operations going on uh across
this city uh there's been over 294
people injured 18 critically the people
in the hospital in a haktai have been
taken to Adana hospital and Emergency
Services again have been called out for
rescue operations now people didn't
expect this there is this sense of how
much more can people expect people uh
they've been president erdogan has said
that over a million people have been
moved out of the earthquake areas into
temporary accommodation but there are
still people here although there are
very few in this city but people are in
the 10 cities that people are in
temporary accommodation and when this
earthquake hit people are just really
really scared I saw people out on the
streets with their children in their
cars blankets around them because the
temperatures are very low just fearful
that another earthquake could strike
there could be strong aftershocks
buildings could collapse because the
ones that are still standing are very
badly damaged
I said beg uh speaking to us there near
the third earthquake that has struck
near the city of antakia